- Korean food is like Korean people,
spicy but sweet, hot and meaty.
(laughing)
(upbeat pop music)
- So I know that if you
live in Los Angeles,
you need to eat Korean BBQ
if you're a fun person,
and I've not done it yet so
maybe I'm not a fun person.
(laughs)
- What's up, why haven't you gone?
- I've heard about Korean
BBQ, but I've never tried it.
- I'm a little weary of
meats that I don't know of.
- Well I've had some Korean BBQ in my day,
and it's good as fuck.
- I've not met one person that
I've introduced to Korean BBQ
who has not fell in love with it.
- That's a lot of pressure for me.
- Yeah.
- Alright, I'm ready, I'm ready for it.
- [Voiceover] I've heard of kimchi
but I don't know what that is.
- So Kimchi is the staple
side dish in Korea.
The best way to put it for people
who don't know Korean food
is just like spicy pickles.
- I think this one's gonna be spicy.
I know you don't like spicy.
- I don't like spicy.
- That smell is just like
hello, good morning, wake up bitch!
- That is spicy.
- Is it?
- Now one thing people don't know
is when you go to a Korean restaurant,
they give you something called banchan,
which is like the
collection of side dishes.
So every time you go
to a Korean restaurant,
you get a whole slew of banchan
that's free and replenishable.
- I don't know how I feel about it.
I don't understand it.
- Kimchi is delicious, but
your breath suffers for weeks.
- Yeah I'm good on that note.
- If you don't like kimchi
then I don't like you.
- [Voiceover] Alright, what's next?
- I'm gonna butcher the name, bulgogi?
- Bulgogi is one of
the staple Korean BBQs.
Generally any cut of beef,
usually flank I would say.
- Well it's similar to brisket.
- The way it's cooked and
the way it's marinated,
that process gives it this
like really deep flavor.
- Mmm, tastes good.
That is pretty good.
- It's delicious.
It's so like thin, it
kinda melts in your mouth.
- But you need some BBQ sauce on it.
- So kalbi has a similar
marinade, but it's a different cut
and it's the prize cut,
it's the short rib.
- Is it inappropriate to just pick it up?
- Ah, just push it off this way.
- But I feel like you can just grab it
by the like thing and just like--
- You can eat it with your hands too,
but you're doing it straight up like
Korean (speaking Korean),
like older Korean guy.
- I can be an older Korean guy.
- Oh.
- Holy fuck!
That is amazing.
- Like melt in your mouth.
- That's really tender.
- No, it's really good.
- I could eat this for
the rest of my life.
- This is a little different
'cause it's already cooked
but you're usually a part
of the cooking process
which is always nice.
- I would definitely go
to like a real joint,
have it cooked in front of me.
I think that would be fun.
- People act like it's a
fun and cool experience
to get to cook your own food,
but I wanted to cook my own
food, I'd do it at home.
- Well that's why people go in big groups.
- You wanna be my date?
- I'll be your Korean BBQ date.
♫ Kimchi in my belly
♫ Got kimchi on my face
♫ If you don't like kimchi
♫ You're a Korean disgrace uh ♫
- That was great!
- Yeah.
- You've been sittin'
on that one for a while.
- Pretty much, yeah.
It's what I think about
every time I eat kimchi.